when I last saw you in San Francisco you
were speaking to a crowd in a local
bookstore in San Francisco a real
establishment here and I mean the crowd
you were rattling up the crowd about
systems change about processes about the
fact that we have to think not about the
issue right now but our democracy as a
whole some yeah voting harder is not
going to get our way out of this Mass
people you know what I mean like that
they segmented us so that our votes are
already pretty much baked into the cake
yeah yeah yeah well I mean the only
legitimate course of action that might
make a difference is if millions of
Americans decided to move to swing
States
if you're not talking about that then
everything else is like essentially just
barking at the wind so I I think that
that fundamentally assumes again our
starting point which is that most
Americans are on the same page that and
maybe not ideologically but they are on
the same page in terms of wanting to
live the life they do but how do you
respond to sort of The Devil's Advocate
the critique of that that assumption
which is that in fact there are deep
systemic divisions that require real
Combat oh they're deep systemic
divisions uh is just the question is
right now is this the way to resolve
them you know like I mean it's like am I
gonna just eke out this one thing I can
like stick it to you for two or four
years and you're gonna Stick it to me in
two four or four years while the
divisions get deeper and more inflamed
that's the course we're on and uh anyone
who thinks that's a path to Salvation I
mean you know I I don't see it really
um so the the question is how can we
change that Dynamic so that there's a
resolution and I would use women's
reproductive rights as a great example
where look right now the majority of
people are not getting what we want in
large part because of the system and
this includes people with ours next to
their name and so if you just decide
look it's team team uh you know blue
versus red then we wind up with this
deranged result that the vast majority
of us don't want
um you should be able to look up and say
you know what
we should try and reorient the system
and then if you get that then you can
put a lot of things in for women's
Reproductive Rights uh you know
reasonable Common Sense firearm
regulation uh uh climate change you name
it I mean right now we're just being set
up uh and it's disintegrating around us
all the time I I remember when I was a a
freshman at UC Berkeley this was like
2017 right after the Miley Annapolis
protest it happened around Free Speech
afterwards we were sitting in this
classroom right and in this classroom
this professor starts talking about the
protests this one student gets up and
starts shouting at this professor
there's like 15 students in this
classroom I mean this was basically my
introduction of politics and that show
this one student stands up Sarah
chatting with Professor saying there's a
bad idea going a little crazy this other
kid gets up starts shouting at the
students so now the students are
shouting at each other right there's two
of them the rest of us 13 are just
sitting there completely silent you know
me being my very you know uh uh normal
you know Asian self-seating authority to
those in power just just sitting back
watching these two go at it 13 of us are
saying I'm like this is insane nobody
says anything we leave the classroom
there are two of us get together we have
a conversation I was like did you like
that nobody like that every everybody
was not nobody was on the same page
everybody felt like this was a terrible
and then I suddenly realized if one of
us had given the other 12 of us the
social permission to stand up and say no
your your method of operating is wrong
it empowers the majority what I see a
hopeful majority of people to actually
do something about it that's just to me
that seems like our politics of the
nutshell there's one person on one side
one person the other it's a tyranny of
the minority in in essence yeah uh it's
what we have to do is give each other
permission and then build a tribe
um whether it's Bridge USA or Ford party
and then say look uh guys
um put the pitchforks uh and we'll talk
cocktails down please uh and let's try
to figure out how we can live together
and maybe even Advance common Solutions
and I refer to a couple of issues
earlier that you know are divine finding
the American people though there is
actually a pretty strong consensus on on
both of them I mean when I I ran for
president I believe certain things I
think most people can figure out where I
am on on a lot of issues I mean heck I
had like 140 policy positions uh during
the presidential but the main impetus
for my running was that I think this
economy is going to become
dehumanizing and punitive and it already
is and then AI is going to come online
and kick everyone to the curb I was just
on the picket line with the actors and
writers in Hollywood and you know I mean
the studios are trying to
scan a thousand background actors and
then never hire a background actor again
which by the way makes perfect sense for
them it's like ah you know what what's
that I need a young handsome South Asian
I've got one right here you know I
should tell my mom back
then you the individual who got scanned
got paid the one time but they don't
have to pay anyone else ever again right
um and and so the actor is like well
that's not cool at all uh you know
they're 160 000 people in that Union
most of whom are you know just showing
up on set every once in a while and um
having uh like a side income that so
that that's something that we can see
very clearly but there's a bunch of
other stuff uh coming down the pike
that's gonna steal up and take people by
surprise I didn't see chat GPT
developing this quickly when I was
running for president even a few years
ago and folks like Tristan Harris who
keep up with us say they literally have
to update their data every day on what
the heck AI is doing it's not like you
could turn away for two months and come
back and it's the same it's literally
like oh changed again so uh you know
who's not changing again just like that
us you know
maybe the next day pretty much the same
you know and maybe a little uh I mean
not only are we not changing enough but
we have yet to figure out how to deal
with social media let alone AI I mean
it's like it feels like it feels like
we're we're studying for for a test in
the eighth grade and the 10th grade AP
test is about to come up around the
corner and we've yet to even open that
book and and it seems like nobody
actually is the incentive to solve the
challenge it almost in some ways and
this might feel a little conspiratorial
but those of us that are outside of the
political scene and only looking in
sometimes feel like those in power are
actually okay with things being bad
because it makes politics much easier
like I feel like if I was the dn's here
the RNC this is exactly the situation I
would want it's just it's red versus
blue it's easy yeah you that that's one
of the perverse aspects of today Manu
where where
um if things deteriorated actually uh is
probably fine for you in the sense that
it's like oh I can get you more animated
uh and upset I mean right now
um there are small dollar donations are
down cycle over cycle by 25 or so right
uh and they're just like oh what are we
gonna do and you I mean the truth is
that we're all burnt out you know we've
all gotten the freaked out emails over
and over again at this point we're like
oh my gosh by like the 300th freaked out
email like I'm not gonna hit the Donate
Button as fast and then like oh no what
are we gonna do
it's like
um by the way in this case too it you
know may not be the worst thing in the
world because it's affecting both sides
so you know it's pretty much canceled
each other out and that uh you know like
Americans might um might be looking for
another
um path forward but yeah the powers that
be don't hate this stuff uh and the
unfortunate truth is that good policy is
probably negatively related to your job
security where if a bunch of people came
forward and said hey here are a bunch of
AI regs there are probably some big time
tech companies that are like oh I didn't
like that uh and meanwhile if they just
grandstand and like say things then
everyone is fine uh to you know like the
problem Fester because the real players
uh are like okay good they're they're
being cool like that you know and we can
handle them saying things about us we
just don't want them to genuinely
regulate us
so amidst all of this where you know
people's paychecks are online people's
job Securities online There's real
policy issues you know people let's say
uh on the side of thinking that climate
change is real threat see the fires in
Hawaii and they want to get out there
somebody that's a conservative sees the
woke culture War issues being rammed
down their Throne they're like this is
insane we got to fight this what is the
fundamental argument from your
standpoint and I have I have a take on
this but I'm curious about yours because
you've pressure tested in front of so
many people what is your fundamental
take
on how you break through that noise to
actually make people think about the
system as opposed to
that really unfortunate you know
disaster event in that certain state or
that really unfortunate job loss that's
about to come around the corner and you
say hey we need to vote for the person
that's voting to ensure that primaries
and gerrymandering are not a thing you
know in the way that they are on the
status quo yeah I I try and explain to
them look right now the incentives are
working against us incentives are
working against good policy and if we
don't change the incentives we're just
going to keep uh grinding ourselves uh
into Oblivion so let's try and fix the
incentives and the way to fix the
incentives are getting rid of primaries
and moving towards all party ranked
Choice voting like they did in Alaska
like they just voted in Nevada and it's
going to be on the ballot again in
Nevada uh that there's a race going on
right now around modernizing the system
and the system crumbling before our eyes
now which do I think is going to win I
mean I'm fighting like mad for the first
one and there are things that people can
do one of the exciting things Manu and
one of the reasons why I'm so pumped to
talk to you is I say to people all the
times like what what percentage of
Americans would you get need to get into
something like forward uh and energize
for us to change everything safe
five percent ten percent that's exactly
right you know you don't need 51 you get
five percent of Americans really zeroed
in on the fights like okay we're being
set up yep um you know you need a
foothold in the population yeah yeah
totally I mean you know you have a 20
approval rating of US Congress and then
a 94 re-elect rate uh of incumbents like
look we're being set up we're getting
carved into blue and red zones and
they're just pounding Us in the head and
saying there's absolutely nothing you
can do so if five percent of us stand up
and say okay I get the game now and I'm
going to shake it up so you have to
listen to the general population instead
of just your cronies and special
interests and the ideological Edge uh
that's where we're going and we will
vote for people that represent that you
get five percent of Americans into it we
change everything
[Music]